[Music]
face off alright louder you're a dude
get welcome back I made a crazy risky
gamble
limits about to pay off I want to suffer
for the cover I want to sell pretend I'm
a garnet rebound what do you know no no
I just know well I'll tell you what I
know it's the dumbest [ __ ] bet I ever
heard of I disagree I disagree Gary
[Music]
taking my money all over town placing
bets I'm having very serious second
thoughts you serious right now I know it
okay Howard where's the money right now
is it too late some time that means
nothing meant nothing please give me
another shot you like to win right this
is no different than that this is my
[ __ ] way you think I'm stupid Howard
you and your whole [ __ ] family
I read you three sermons your [ __ ]
swimming pool makes me feel no who said
that I told you about how things are
gonna go you like the way things are
going now
the kids got it out yeah having a good
time yes this is me this is how I win
game now you should be stretching out
your coast no just a [ __ ] crazy as
you
[Music]